-Adam Sandler, welcome back.
Thank you for coming on.
-I love you.
So good to see you.
-It is always great
to see you, pal.
It's great to have you here.
-You got my beard.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm copying everything you ever
did with your career.
I want to be you, man.
Come on.
-Is it itchy?
Itchy?
-I'm over the itchy phase.
-Oh, yeah.
The itchy phase was tough.
-Do you wash yours good?
-Yeah.
Do you wash it?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I shampoo it.
-Don't you forget
to do that sometimes?
And then you go,
"Ah, I forgot to shampoo it."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm getting a lot of gifts,
beard gifts.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Brushes and oils and things.
Are you doing that, too?
-Uh, I get -- yeah, yeah.
But I hate that oil feel
'cause it feels like it gets
on your regular cheek.
-Yeah.
-And then you feel like
you got greasy cheek.
[ Laughter ]
-You got greasy cheek.
-But did you grow that
for "Hustle"?
-I --
I grew it for many reasons.
[ Laughter ]
-You look good.
You look good in it, man.
It looks fantastic.
-No, no.
-You were telling me backstage
I gotta get serious with you.
-Why?
-You told me backstage
you had hip surgery.
-I had hip surgery, everybody.
It was sad.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Dude, I feel --
What happened?
What are you talking about?
-It was funny.
So, I was --
It was aching.
My groin was aching.
And then they said
it was in my hip.
I thought it was my groin,
but it was my hip.
So, I get the surgery.
And you've got to replace --
You replace your hip
when your hip's bad.
[ Laughter ]
So, I go to the doctor
in the morning, very nice.
You get the surgery.
And I'm sitting in the bed.
And the man anesthesiologist --
is that how you say it?
-Yeah.
-He says, "All right.
We're gonna knock you out.
We're gonna put you
on some drugs."
So they put me
on some light drugs.
And then he said,
"We're gonna amp it up,
but when we bring you
into the operating room,
what music would
you like to listen to?"
And I go, "What do I mean?
Why am I listening to music?"
And then he goes, "Well, we like
to keep it fun in there."
And I go -- and I was already
a little dazed
from the mild drugs.
And so I'm going, "Uh..."
He goes, "Who do you like?"
I go, "I don't know.
I don't know who I like."
And so, he goes,
"I listened to Dolly Parton
on the way here."
And I go, "Yeah? Yeah?"
He goes,
"Do you like Dolly Parton?"
I go, "I think everybody
likes Dolly Parton."
[ Laughter ]
And then he's like,
"Yeah, all right."
So, brings me in
the operating room
or whatever it is
and amps up the whatever.
-Yeah.
And you start falling asleep?
-I'm not -- with the groin,
they have to numb --
I mean, with the hip,
they have to numb the bottom
like if you're having a baby.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So, they're numbing that,
so he has to keep me awake,
on drugs but be awake,
but he's holding me up, right?
They're holding me forward,
and they're drugging me
through the back
or something like that.
And the man's face is right next
to mine, the anesthesiologist.
And I'm hearing this music,
and it's thumping.
And it's going
boof boof, doo doo --
It's, like, a rockin' tune.
-Yeah.
-And he's talking to me.
And I'm so on drugs
that I'm going,
"Am I supposed to answer you?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm looking at his mouth,
it's moving.
I'm going, "Oh, he's
definitely looking at me.
He's definitely
asking questions."
And then I start going,
"But maybe I already responded."
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm just kind of
looking nuts.
And then I just --
I got no words out.
And I was going,
"Man, this is -- this is heavy."
And then he's looking at me,
and he's, like,
giving me a head nod goodbye.
And the only words that came out
of my mouth were,
"This isn't Dolly Parton."
[ Laughter ]
And I was out.
-"That's not Dolly Parton."
Everyone loves Dolly Parton.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Which, uh --
which hip got replaced?
-My left hip,
which would be a great movie.
But, uh --
[ Laughter ]
But my --
"Did you see 'My Left Hip'?"
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Anyway, so my wife was nervous
about my --
when I went into surgery
that they were gonna operate
on the wrong hip.
-That happens, yeah.
-That happens.
Sometimes they make a mistake.
So she wrote on my right hip,
"No."
[ Laughter ]
So there was a big "No"
in big, thick magic marker.
-That's nice of her, though.
-The sad part -- I wake up,
and the no is still there,
and there's an arrow
pointing to my penis.
[ Laughter ]
-That doctor's funny!
I like that.
-The doc-- yeah.
-The doctor's funny.
I like that doctor.
-Yes.
-Can I say, you're on the cover
of "AARP" magazine.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Congratula--
[ Laughs ]
-That, uh -- that came
with the hip surgery.
[ Laughter ]
-You get a hip surgery, they...
-They just got -- they called me
up, they said, "We heard."
[ Laughter ]
"It's time.
It's time, old man."
Jimmy, my kids are here.
-Sunny?
-Yeah, Sunny and Sadie.
Yeah, they're right over here.
-Where are they?
Oh, yeah.
Hi, guys!
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah, yeah, they came.
They've never been here!
-They've never been?
-They love you.
-Oh, my gosh.
You guys kidding me?
I've known you
throughout the whole years.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Look at you.
Welcome.
Isn't it fun to see dad up here?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-It is, yeah, okay, yeah.
Did they see you
when you're on tour?
-They hear me curse, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
When you do stand-up,
when you do stand-up.
-They have come to my shows.
I don't know if they --
You've come to --
Did you come --
-Once.
-Sometimes they come on stage
when I go do tours,
and they come and sing a tune.
-Oh, really?
-They come out and sing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-What is the song
that you guys like to sing?
-Taylor Swift.
-Yeah.
-Taylor Swift, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, yeah.
Swifties.
Yeah, we're all Swifties.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, that's fun.
I wanted to ask you
about this tour
because I follow you
on Instagram.
And I see you're not doing,
like, just theaters
or clubs or whatever.
You're doing stadiums
and arenas.
-A lot of times,
it's big places, yeah.
-That's unbelievable.
-It's very cool.
-I've been -- I started up --
Like, I started
doing stand-up again like
four or five years ago,
and now I run around and do it
for a couple weeks at a time.
And, yeah, it's been fun.
I did my hometown.
I played my hometown.
I grew up in Manchester,
New Hampshire.
-That's right.
-And I played,
for the first time,
in my hometown.
I gotta tell you,
I was so nervous.
When you play your hometown,
there's something about it.
I just didn't want to let
my family down and stuff.
So, I'm on the side.
I was just terrified, you know?
-Is that right?
-I really was.
-But you're Adam Sandler.
-I -- I -- I --
[ Laughter ]
They were so nice to me!
And, like, everywhere I walked,
people backstage are going,
"Ah, welcome home, Adam,"
and all this great stuff.
So I was like --
Every time they were nice to me,
I was like,
"Oh, please,
don't let these guys down."
-How'd you do?
-I ended up doing --
It was just warm.
It was great.
They were so nice to me.
It took me like
10, 15 minutes to be able
to not be so nervous.
You know that weird feeling
sometimes --
Even when you come out
to do this show,
Sometimes you're out of body,
and you're saying words,
and you don't know
what's happening.
But I had that for a little bit,
but then I started locking in
on the crowd,
and they were just great to me.
And then, my mom was there,
and it was her 85th birthday.
And, like, everyone sang
"Happy Birthday" to her.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Happy birthday, Mom!
-Yeah, grandma.
-She's got to be proud.
And she's got
some great grandkids.
-Yes, yes, yes, yes.
[ Laughs ]
-Can we talk about "Hustle"?
Your movie, "Hustle,"
by the way,
is streaming
on Netflix right now.
You're getting -- okay, sure.
Give it up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You're getting rave reviews.
There's even some awards buzz
for you.
-That's weird.
-And earlier this week --
-No, it's well-deserved.
-It's cool. Thank you.
-Earlier this week,
you were honored with --
you got
a Performer Tribute Award
at the Gotham Awards right here
in New York City.
-Yes, yes.
-Congrats on that.
-Thank you, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You were here.
It was amazing.
-I have to --
It's nice,
people being nice to me,
and thank you.
But I, like, have to wear
to these award get-togethers,
I gotta dress up.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't --
You know, I'm not goo--
I just don't like it.
I don't -- but I --
And my wife dresses up,
and she looks great.
And it's kind of -- you know,
I should look good for her.
So, I --
[ Laughter ]
But every time I say,
like, I give myself --
"Hey, that thing's on Thursday.
I should get a suit,"
and then I go,
"Oh, it's already Wednesday."
[ Laughter ]
And I always end up
just wearing my --
Sunny's bat mitzvah
was like six months ago,
so I always wear
the bat mitzvah suit.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the one suit you wear?
-That's the only thing I change.
I don't even change the tie.
The tie -- everything --
The socks.
Sometimes I change my socks,
but no one sees that.
[ Laughter ]
-I gotta say, it's well-deserved
that you're getting these things
and the awards buzz
because, you know, I'm a fan,
but this movie moved people.
-Ah, thank you, buddy.
-It was awesome.
-Queen Latifah, baby.
-That's my pal.
That's my buddy.
-Yeah.
-She's fantastic in it.
-Yes.
-Everyone's in it.
But, also,
who's the basketball player?
-Juancho Hernangomez.
He's phenomenal in the movie.
-Phenomenal.
And you two together.
And, like --
-Oh, what a nice guy.
He's just the sweetest guy,
not an actor, doesn't care
about acting at all, but just --
He plays for Toronto.
He's playing a lot now.
He's playing great.
And he just did --
It's just amazing
to be with a guy
who doesn't care
that he's good at something.
He's a great actor.
Every time, after every take,
I go, "How did you do that?
It was amazing."
He'd be like, "Do what?"
[ Laughter ]
-But it's like, I would say,
it's like a "Rocky"
for basketball kind of.
-Ah, yeah, that's good.
-I felt so good.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Like, it's just moving.
It's exactly what you want,
and you're like,
"Keep working, keep going,
keep trying."
-Yeah, right, right.
-It's also funny.
But you're amazing in it.
-Thank you.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Adam Sandler in "Hustle."
Take a look at this.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Obsession's gonna beat talent
every time.
You got all the talent in the
world, but are you obsessed?
Is it all you ever think about?
Let's face it --
it's you against you out there.
When you walk on that court,
you have to think,
"I am the best guy out there."
I don't care
if LeBron's playing!
So, let me ask you again --
do you love this game?
♪♪
-Yes.
-Is there a newborn kitten
purring in here right now?
I couldn't hear you.
Do you want to be in the NBA?
-Yes!
-Well, let's make that happen.
Never back down.
-Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
-Whoa.
-That's how you do it!
Adam Sandler, everybody!
-Thank you.
Thank you, guys!
-"Hustle" is streaming now
on Netflix!
Catch Adam on his stand-up tour,
"Adam Sandler Live."
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪